on one language she'll focus on security
forces are getting ready this bill
includes firing teargas and crowd
control procedures it's all in
preparation for an opposition march on
the capital Islamabad meanwhile the
leader of the protest march is making
preparations of his own maulana father
Ramon inspects his men from internal
Islam a component of the Jui
who've been tasked to maintain order
during the rally now Angela the comment
is failed to perform leading to -
inflation and a solution of the country
we have a common cause and it's why we
will come peace now but and won't accept
anything short of Imran Khan's
resignation someone is the one with a
connection my anguish but some are
concerned that the men are wearing what
looks like military uniforms the move
has prompted the government to ban the
outfit saying political parties cannot
have such militias tens of thousands of
people are likely to take part in what
the opposition is calling a long march
is expected to bring people from all
over Pakistan starting on the 27th and
reaching the capital on the 31st of
October they are likely to be joined by
traders doctors and teachers who are
already waiting countrywide protests
against the government the opposition is
also hoping to capitalize on what it
says is a poor performance by Imran
Khan's government they also accused Han
of coming to power through a rigged
election but the government says
previous administrations are to blame
for the poor economy and corruption it's
now trying to defuse tensions but it's
also preparing to stop the march at
certain locations the security forces
have already started sealing access into
Islamabad the red zone which houses
Parliament the diplomatic Enclave and
other sensitive government buildings and
the prime minister says that despite the
pressure from the opposition he will not
resign the government says the mouse
could not have come at a worse time
it says Pakistan is confronting grave
traits in
rising tensions with India over Kashmir
for now the information minister says
negotiations are the way to go
dialogue dialogue and dialogue and we
are holding dialogues today with them we
want to know their agenda we want to
know their demands we want to know their
objectives and I am sure that dialogue
is the only way forward what happens in
the next few days will be critical and
perhaps the biggest test of Imran Khan's
leadership kamal Haider al Jazeera
Islamabad